dude pulled up you know what I'm saying
and my dad's like what the [__] I don't
even think my dad realized who this dude
was right right yeah and he hops out on
my dad with the pistol
the ice cream man came back with a piece
yes and [__] next thing you know like
I'm watching this go down and of course
it's happening so fast my dad screams
get you get the [__] in the house and so
I run in the house and like by the time
I get to the house and I'm looking
through the window like my dad just
thought you just all you see is weed
whacker
you know what I'm saying my dad is
beating the [__] out of dude with the
weed whack that's feeding the ice cream
man with a weed whacker and he's got the
gun
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]
foreign